they may an [ __ ] period and that
pretty much covers it and also you can
go right into the Golden Rule treat
people like you want to be treated
hey they're loaded Willy
in the 1930s Willie Nelson was a
small-town kid he was also an extreme
nose-picker he pick until he bled and
Willie became an easy target for bullies
when I was like six years old my
grandmother had taught me this point I
said what are you looking at me for I
ain't got nothing to say if you don't
like the looks of me you can just look
the other way I thought it was so funny
I started live in that way he learned to
ignore the teasing and look the other
way and years later that lesson still
stands well I think you have to follow
your feelings do what your conscience
tells you to do if you feel like you can
do anything whether it's this college or
that cause I think you're obligated to
do it for Willie offering a helping hand
has played an important role
he supported dozens of environmental and
humanitarian causes over the years I
feel like we're all responsible for each
other you know you can see somebody I'll
need some help you help them maybe
somebody's Carol and a ditch you help
them or it out I'd like to think that we
all try to be as good an example as we
can be
others to our kids or to